assalamualaikum warahmatullahi what I
care to and welcome to a special show
with a special guest who is a weaker
Muslim who is an activist who's been
very active on media mainstream media
BBC T is equal T NT or T RT a crabber
yeah yeah the Turkish channel right Al
Jazeera and many other and many other
important channels it's obviously got
very important information to give us
today about the plight of the weakened
Muslims in East Turkestan so before we
get started with what's happening on the
ground now I thought we potentially
better get started with maybe a brief
history of who are the weaker people and
what is the history of of those bigger
people in the East segment son sure um
today what what the Chinese call or what
it's officially called by the world
bodies as the Xin Jiang we got
autonomous region we often refer to as
Chinese occupied East Turkestan and I
mean you could go in 2000 years of
history but maybe the week is coming to
play especially during the Qatar Han
Empire period where the wiggers in 934
accept Islam and they are the first
Turkic nation to accept this lab and and
make a kingdom out of it they make the
first Kingdom and even the word Google
in Turkish regard actually means
civilize because they were the first
shows generally Turkic / Mongol people
are nomadic people and the week is were
the first branch of Turks to leave that
nomadic lifestyle and create a
civilization in agriculture and so
around 900 they accept Islam and then
it's like a few hundred years of within
a week a kingdom of different sort of
kingdoms within Turkey kingdoms it's not
until we get to about 1760 where we
start having issues with the Chinese
Empire and during that time we get into
contact the wiggers get into contact
with a Manchu Empire
and they take over what we now refer to
as East Turkestan in 1760 they sort of
rule that part of the land and we'll get
into the geography as well for about 80
or so years during those 80 years there
are many revolts and in about 1864 the
week has become independent once more
from the Manchu Empire and then during
that period for the for a very brief
period the week is actually give back to
the Ottoman empires world very briefly
but again it's short-lived and we are
taken over by the Manchurians again in
1876 then for about eight years or so
there's a bit more revolt and then the
the Ching dynasty basically during that
period in 1884
we are labeled as Shin Jung which
literally means new frontier or new land
and then it's not until 1911 that the
Manchu Empire totally is wiped out by
the Chinese nationalists and we fall
under chinese nationalist rule and then
from 1911 to about 1933 we we fight the
Chinese nationalists and we establish
the East Turkestan Islamic Republic and
this is was established in the city of
kashgar which is very close to the which
which orders with Afghanistan and it's
actually recognized by but by the Afghan
government back then and also turkey the
Turkish Republic but unfortunately this
Islamic Republic is short-lived and then
we lose the fight to the Chinese
nationalists once more and then in in
about eleven years later in 1944 towards
the north of East Turkestan in the city
of gujja we established the East
Turkestan Republic and that goes on for
about five or six years until the
Chinese Communist disband that
government in 1949 and then we've been
living for the past 70 odd years and
communist rule Chinese communist rule
together with Tibet together with Inner
Mongolia and since that day they
promised us autonomy technically we are
labeled the shinjang we got enemies
region but we have we don't receive any
autonomy our leaders are puppets and we
and we've gone through many oppressions
throughout the times whether it be
during whether it be our own Arabic
script because we do use Arabic script
that was then later changed into Latin
for a period of time just like what
Turkey did with Ataturk but then later
again they changed it back to Arabic so
one you change the Arabic script once
you lose a whole generation of people
they become in the room and in another
20 years you change the script once more
so the Chinese have been keeping the the
Weig as literate
[Music]
you know not knowledged and not schooled
and this is a typical of all communist
regimes you know attacking professors
attacking the rich attacking the
businessman and in attacking agency
basically I could go on until today
basically if you if you'd like or well I
mean that's that's very comprehensive in
the short space of time history
tree-like of the of the Weir's what are
the population sizes just for people to
get kind of more of a visual picture now
what's what is the population size what
language do people speak tell us more
about these people I mean to what extent
are they integrated into Chinese society
if at all to what extent are they likely
to know Mandarin Chinese or any kind of
Chinese so give us a bit of a glimpse as
to what what the wiggers are like today
and and something about the week of
people yes so the week is by nature by
nature or by say blood are a link to the
Turks so even when you go to Turkey or
when you talk to Turkish people they
they have this special tree of you know
what they call like where their gene
comes from or so to speak so we are
linked to the Turkic people
and when we refer to East Turkestan we
don't just refer to the wiggers even
though we make the majority within the
framework of Turkestan or Eastern
castaigne Kazakh Turks is Beck Turks
Kurds Turks hotter Turks the the wiggers
the language itself is Turkish so if I
were to speak say say - Ali Dawa very
slowly in the wiggling which you would
understand me I do know the Turkish
language itself as well so that the
Turks understand each other and the
language wise according to Chinese
statistics we are 11 million people but
we say we are anywhere anywhere between
25 to 40 million obviously the Chinese
don't let us do any statistics they seem
to just keep our population the same
over especially after 1990 our
population hasn't changed for some
reason they like to keep it small on
paper and when the first when before
China's invasion the the Chinese
population is Turkestan was less than a
percent maybe like half a percent but
now according to China it's about 50 50
50 percent Han and then 50 percent we
guess and then within that 50 percent
there are a small minority of Cossacks
could his respects Attar's yeah but
those are the weaker people for you and
the frustration with the Chinese
government is that while whilst many
other cultures because China posts
itself and prides itself of having 56
nationalities within or 56 ethnic groups
within China but we are the ones that
haven't necessarily integrated into
there or been assimilated into their
framework and it's maybe you've heard of
the recent crackdown in the last three
years these concentration camps where
they finally said enough is enough
you're either going to become Chinese or
not because how our allegiance has not
been necessarily to Beijing it's been
more
towards to our Turkic brothers in
Central Asia to to our Middle Eastern
brothers in the Middle East so we looked
out and even the way we look the way we
speak in recent years I mean the the
weaker people have had to learn Chinese
I mean it is it is that is it is the
nation's language after all if you don't
know Chinese you wouldn't be able to
study so weak is predominantly do you
know the Chinese Mandarin language yeah
and you may have heard that and we'll
probably get into that later that why
they're putting us into concentration
camp is to teach us Chinese Mandarin but
most of the people that that you've seen
put are actually very educated people so
let's get to that right now because I
think we've got a good picture of who
the weaker people are what the history
is because I think that he realizes them
not just for let's say non-muslims who
are watching this but also for us
Muslims who might not have much
information about the weekers myself
included so I think it's very important
that we we do study a little bit more
about the history studied a little bit
more about the society and the people
what's going on in China now so the most
recent thing that has been going on
especially since the beginning of 2017
China have decided to put the wiggers
into and and we've seen it and today I
made a video about it as well just like
what happened to the Jews into
concentration camps before I mean it's
not like it's starting 2017 the the
weeks have always been oppressed over
the last 70 years but especially these
last three years regardless of how
religious someone is or regardless of
how loyal they were to the Communist
Party it based simply on your ethnic
identity you were put into this
concentration camp to be basically fixed
or to be retrained re-educated and in
the process many have died so if I if I
can go into what actually happened
in these camps there are actually four
types of camps for four levels of camps
the first type of camp is the lightest
where probably the people that have that
are not a threat to society so sort of
threats to Chinese society is if you
have connections overseas if you make a
telephone call overseas if you have if
you if you have ever owned any religious
items so holding on to prayer mats or
Koran or hanging things or saying I
don't know if you've got religious or
possessions or so you can check this out
as well
1.1 million Chinese officials were sent
in to
Weger homes and and you had no choice
for this under the guise of creating
ethnic harmony between the Han and the
Wigga and we thought you know this is
good all right that they'll get to know
what it'll be like a cultural exchange
because it's very easy very I mean even
though we cousin Han Chinese do work
together it's it's very unlikely that
you would invite that let have them
sleep over and all this during that time
the wigs were surveilled and they saw
how they interacted so this notion of or
they could practice at home and not
practice outside that doesn't exist for
us so during that time they were able to
establish how whether how much Chinese
Mandarin they spoke at home because now
in public spaces the weaker language
itself is banned so how what sort of
lessons were they teaching their kids
and it could be things like not even at
fully Islamic like my son eat with your
right hand
like there's no sir you know you don't
even have to say all the the the
Shaitaan eats with his left it's just
available white with his right hand so
all these things are jotted down and
jotted in and so from this they sort of
gather who's at what degree so the
lightest punishment is basically this
first sort of care will you literally go
to like work from 9:00 to 5:00 your
this is the lightest is the actual camp
where you are Satan and you actually
stay you live there people have told us
former detainees have told us and this
is widely covered in Western media and
east media they were on four to five
hundred calorie diets they were made to
repent macabre to Xi Jinping and there
are signs out on the streets and again
this is everything that I'm gonna say is
recorded you can do your own research of
this that Xi Jinping is literally God
and they haven't have a TV screen on him
and you need to write letters to him and
so people are making Toba because they
were making tawba to Allah so religion
not just Islam Christianity Buddhism
Falun Gong you may have heard of these
groups any religion and this is under
all communist regimes are banned even
though they have stayed one religion
where they propagate their own communism
and it's not real religion so that's the
main sort of concentration camp that
we're talking about where there are four
to five hundred calorie diets women are
sterilized they are injected with
something but but the the former
detainees the women they were saying
they they they ended up not having their
periods there is gang rape regardless of
men and women even some men have
testified that they were gang-raped by
prison guards and once the evidence
would miss all of the evidence is based
on testimony and number two there is
satellite images of the actual camps but
video footage of actually what's
happening no we don't have any footage
of this so it's based on testimony the
mowjood the the realization of the camps
have been seen on through google images
through google maps and whenever any
foreign visitor investigate the
journalist does want to go to a specific
area and follow those addresses on the
maps that were given they are stopped if
there is nothing to hide why stopping
them and so for example i've seen
yourself for example going to a row
Hinda going to you know these very
delicate sensitive places
you would not be able to do that in East
Turkestan you want to be able to
interview the people so that's the
second solo that's it that's the second
camp the third camp yeah what ask you
just on that point yeah how would you
compare the wigger situation with the
ring gear situation you know as you kind
of mentioned I'm gonna go into Burma but
I went to Cox's Bazar which is on the
account of all the with Burma and I
spoke to many of the women said that
they seemed their own children you know
put into fires and burn alive and gang
rape but all this first sinister stuff I
was gonna ask to what extent now is that
comparable with what's going on in China
are we seeing the same kind of thing as
it is it just genocide or killings and
I've been what kind of numbers are we
talking about is there anywhere similar
to running game but would you say it's
lesser than that we just say it's
similar to it in many ways or what would
be your assessment so basically based
based on what the former detainees have
said they're saying anyway based on
their experiences on average they were
saying they were at least seeing ten
people every month leaving their cells
and not being able to come back this is
what they were telling us that they
actually saw ten people die in front of
their eyes every month they're saying
that there's anywhere between 1,000 to
2,000 camps so you can only guesstimate
there are no official numbers I mean
killing them yes that they are killing
them but that they're killing them in a
way that they are they're being put
through this camp but the people that
are dying and not being they are not
able to take that torture it's not like
a bullet to your head but just through
those lack of nutrition through the
torture through someone's questions
well what kind of torture methods are we
talking about it sohow yeah yeah what so
so we're talking about
we're talking about sitting on wood
there is a special made chairs you may
have heard them Tiger chairs for some of
the detainees have said 15 to 16 hours
at a time and when they're or they are
made to stand in certain positions for
many hours at a time
they are interrogated they are given
pills or they're given these special
injections so that they don't fall
asleep after a while if you're not
sleeping for days on end through these
through torture methods the human body
isn't able to take it and say so you
have tens of people die from each cell
this this is how they are dying
generally this is what the detainees are
saying it's not straight up like for
example the the footage that you see
coming out of Inga they you can at least
get footage of you can see the people
dying but in East Turkestan this is
impossible because everything is done
under closed doors it's the difference
between the two and to be honest there
are hinder or the Burma the government
there or the regime they don't have the
capacity to do what cause china has the
the economic power to keep it under
wraps and we're basically saying if
they're not if they haven't got anything
to hide why are journalists you know
constantly followed they are not able to
report freely and still to this day no
UN investigators are able to come and
you people that you were able to go to
the border in and talk to the people
that went through this this oppression
whereas you would never be able to do
this in Kyrgyzstan or um but you could
talk to people outside say in the UK or
in the West so that's a second
personally of you see yes yes I walk
again with it so basically the last time
I was there in 2014 basically from a
child I've been going there every 3 3 or
4 years my mum will take me and we would
stay as a mum son in three four or five
months at a time
and basically for me me going there as a
foreigner I don't really see much post
to
2009 2009 you may have heard there was
something called the autumn chili
massacre or the orange shy riots which
stemmed from the wiggers in this place
called Guangdong which is part of China
these we Gers were working in toy
factories in China why were we was
working over there because there is this
a mr. Sweden to another issue where
where the child the Han Chinese are
called over to work in East Turkestan
the jobs the homes the all the
advantages are for them and we just
don't have anything don't benefit
economically we girls are sent to work
in these factories to make our phones to
make cashews we've heard that Chinese
labor is cheap but we go labor is
cheaper so what happened in 2009 was in
sha1 on June 26 2009 we because the
Chinese workers was not happy they were
losing their jobs because of wiggers
many weekers were slaughtered massacred
by workers and it was a huge cover-up
the Chinese government didn't release it
to the news so the wiggers in East
Turkistan went to the government the
central government and told them look 10
days ago this happened why I what what
what have you done about this said they
did they did nothing so on the 5th of
July 2009 the we're peacefully and they
were met with gunfire they literally
were met with the square but
the East Turkestan version of square for
that next year we had no internet access
with them and so they were able to round
up people killed we estimate anywhere
between 10 to 20 thousand of our youth
were slaughtered many of my family
members but many of my friends who
living overseas
most of them lost family members and
your family members now I'm not and they
would not get in contact with me because
one I'm overseas and two I'm an activist
as well big no-no
so I did go to East Turkestan post 2009
and it was different even I was being
checked before I wasn't checked at the
border they
I was going through little things but
when I got there when I was hooking to
the people they would be like you know
what you should stay in the big city
doesn't go to the little other little
towns because each time that you go to
you're going to be registered and there
has to be like what you said like a
caffeine or like like a guarantor they
have to take care of you and if you if
you're out of place if you do anything
wrong they get in trouble and simply me
being there and staying at a wig is home
in itself is very dangerous it's not at
the danger now where you're not allowed
to stay at just any random person's home
for a foreigner now you can't just stay
at people's homes I think you have to
register at a hotel so yeah so I post
2009 it's it's it's slowly been like
they're the the cultural filter or what
your what your able to say what you're
able to do whether it be on social media
or just arm Street has been slowly your
freedoms are slowly slowly being taken
away but every ten years since 1949
there's always been like a culling of
the wiggers now and so yeah so that's
the second type of can the third type of
camp is and that is an actual prison or
you're actually sentenced your Center
for for I wouldn't say reasons I would
say excuses so it would be like you are
praying okay ten years um you you were
using whatsapp or you had very come
people get any some people get twenty so
some people say oh they gathered people
in their home to pray that they were
praying say a shot together so the
little things like is for owning a Koran
for saying salaam-o-alaikum for saying
and for example if you tell someone and
they overhear brother don't do that
Haram that you know that in itself is a
crime and you have to be that there is a
cancer there is a tumor in your mind and
this is quoting the Chinese government
I'm not saying to Mayan cancer from my
mind from their documents that were
leaked last year they said
is to mana is cancer which is Islam
needs to be removed these people have
been extreme effects trimmed and then
the fourth type of sort of camp is the
fourth labor where people they say well
this uneducated youth we have to give
them jobs but when you talk to these
people they were earning anywhere
between one thousand one thousand five
hundred US dollars which is good money
and now they're down to that 200
American dollars that they're making and
and and the main narrative that the
Chinese give is we gotta educate the
youth there are no Chinese that are not
the law but they're locking up even 40
year-olds 50 year old six-year-olds as I
mentioned my own father-in-law who is a
famous actor and comedian you've simply
type in his name into YouTube his name
is Arden VG Adi elves face mi JIT is a
everyone knows him is the equivalent to
Jim Carrey or Michael McIntyre in the UK
even he was placed in a camp and he
studied with Xi Jinping's wife at the
central academy of drama and arts in
Beijing in the mid 80s
so people who code this the CCP line
were even sent to these camps and are
still amazed and he was lucky enough to
be released last September but he has
still not called us in Turkey it's very
bleak you know and very horrible to be
honest you know image that you've given
us of what's going on people will be
wondering now what can we do about this
I mean what are the steps while the
productive steps we can use to move
forward and how can we follow your work
in particular and help you with your
what you're doing so basically what we
do is we we basically do our work from
Twitter and Facebook and we also team up
with other activists as well and also
Western organizations like Amnesty
International Human Rights Watch and so
you gotta imagine that these
organizations if there was really a
terror issue or an extreme issue they
wouldn't come near us at all if this was
really the case on Visa Western elite
organized
human rights organization yes so we work
so we work specifically with say groups
like the world with Congress or we get
Human Rights Project so and - so we feed
off each other we share each other's
work we talk in different
what is your is your Twitter so my
Twitter is add arts Lancer ARS LAN
underscore he diet HIV aya tea and the
Facebook pages talk to is Turkestan it's
the most popular Weger Facebook page and
the only reason why we got home ela cork
- East Turkestan it's like - number 2 or
T oh yeah okay yeah yeah Facebook or you
can just type in my name and you see me
all that Google anyway yes they can see
you on the screen as well yes so we were
talking about how important social media
is so I'll just tell you a little story
what happened last year I want everyone
to look up the term 50 cent social media
army you can google this and this is
literally 50 cent social media army and
if you simply google this you will see
the money that the Chinese that the
Chinese government pays its citizens to
basically from writing comments and
posting comments supporting or anti
wigger or antique tibetan or anti hong
kong to go against these movements from
making videos saying you know
stay strong UK you know you know you'll
get over the coronavirus and all this so
we got these people they attacked our
page all right with comments and
bringing down our rating and they posted
it and they SH and they got written by
the club Global Times which is a Chinese
CCP Channel which boosted our what he
call it our presence CNN got in touch
with us and you can find these articles
on CNN talking about how our page was it
before you when you say us who are you
talking about in particular also me and
there is another Brotherhood given in
sabe we run East Turkestan talk these
two stand together
right yeah and so through the Facebook
page yeah and and so they promoted a
page and basically what I'm trying to
say is for the Chinese mentality of the
of the Chinese government is that they
want to save face so even little
Facebook I mean we've only got like
60,000 followers little Facebook pages
like us the Chinese regime finds us a
threat and we'll find anyone who speaks
about the Whig issue the the Tibetan
issue or any other oppressed peoples in
China no matter how small you are they
will try and ridicule you or or they'll
make you as fake with spreading fake
news and our argument has always been
what if we're so fake let us in let the
people in let the likes of yourself in
and talk to the people why are PR are
the week to week is get in trouble get
put in jail for talking to journalists
and so so don't think that what we do on
social media or others don't social
media every little bit hashtagging
sharing the material that we've got
listening to us telling your friends and
family
it may seem small but it's really huge
and we just need people to be aware of
this because in a few days time
inshallah to Allah Ramadan is starting
and like what a few moments ago you are
comparing the raw anger and but I am I
always compare also philistine because
in philistine inshallah may Allah
relieve the Dunham's of the Palestinian
brothers and sisters from the Israeli
Zionists but to now the Palestinians
will still be able to fast this Ramadan
they will still be able to wear the
hijab they'll still have the beard
they'll still be able to pray they'll
still be able to read advance they'll
still be able to give their kids Muslim
names they'll still be able to read
Arabic talking Arabic
still be able to protest they'll still
be able to call their Dell and
Philistine in Phyllis the word is
Turkestan is banned in East Turkestan if
the word itself what we're doing now is
illegal if we were enjoying in strictest
time right now so I would like people to
think about these things ahead of
Ramadan yeah well I mean I was just
having a conversation with Chomsky
yesterday yeah he said something which I
think we can end with which is and you
know it's very important to first note
before before I do that that I've been
enlightened by I love what you said I
want to thank you for coming on the show
and I want to thank you once again I
want to reiterate your Twitter what was
that again ad artist lon so my name the
ars lan underscore he died at hid a y8e
and the Facebook poke is talk to his
cookie stop so he said using social
media if we don't use it you know the
biggest erases will so this is you know
in a manner for us to to put this this
case forward and and this is a very
important thing that needs to be
highlighted
but it's investigated by Western media
streams I thank you again for coming on
the show and for enlightening us
historical perspective it's surely
enough from a political one as well
thank you very much arsalan today it
thank you for having me